mes chers compatriotes c'est avec une
profonde tristesse que je prends
connaissance de l'ignoble attaque
terroriste perpétrée à l'église
saint-etienne du rouvray en assassinant
un prêtre catholique en blessant
gravement
des fidèles dans une église c'est aussi
l'âme de la france qui est touché la
france est une nouvelle fois prise pour
cible pour ce qu'elle incarne et pour ce
qu'elle représente
j'adresse mes pensées les plus émues les
plus solidaires ou catholiques français
et à l'église de france
si cruellement éprouvés par cette
tragédie
après l'attentât de nice notre pays est
donc une fois encore frappé par la
barbarie dans des circonstances
particulièrement inhumaine l'émotion de
la nation est immense cette situation
doit nous conduire à la plus grande
lucidité et a en fait comprendre que
nous devons changer profondément la
dimension la mesure la stratégie de
notre riposte
notre ennemi n'a pas d'abo n'a pas de
limite n'a pas de morale n'a pas de
frontières nous devons être impitoyable
les arguties juridiques les précautions
les prétextes à une action incomplète ne
sont pas admissibles
je demande au gouvernement de mettre en
oeuvre toutes les propositions que nous
avons présentées depuis des mois
sans délai nous ne pouvons plus perdre
de temps
c'est la guerre il n'ya pas d'autre
choix que de l'amener et de la gagner je
vous remercie